l'enlisement du conflit au proche-orient
conduit certains à verser désormais dans
l'extrémisme et à utiliser pour défendre
leurs idées politiques des méthodes
détestables qu'on croyait d'un autre âge
un site internet pro israélien publie
une liste de personnalités juives accusé
de défendre une solution pacifique
des menaces sont même proféré laetitia
legendre lors on dit et béatrice notoire
monsieur je suis triste et j'ai même
honte d'avoir eu un jour de l'iss tim
voire de l'admiration pour axel kahn à
son retour de vacances a eu la
désagréable surprise de découvrir dans
son courrier des dizaines de lettres
d'insultés
il est dénoncé par des sites internet
sioniste pour son soutien à la paix au
proche orient sur le site en question
des noms d'écrivains de politique de
scientifiques un sort particulier est
réservée aux personnalités juives
considérés comme des traîtres qu'il y
avait effectivement des gens qui à un
moment donné à travers des manoeuvres de
ce type là introduisent un racisme dont
leur père ont tant souffert
ce sont des inconscients ce sont des
assassins depuis la fin de la matinée il
n'est plus possible de consulter l'un
des sites en question
il appelle selon le monde à boycotter
toutes les vermines antijuive pour les
traîtres
un crachat ou même un bon coup de batte
de baseball face à cet appel que
certains dénoncent comme un lynchage
le mrap a déposé plainte contre les
auteurs du site hébergé au panama c'est
extrêmement grave
au plan du racisme parce qu'on touche
aux méthodes fascisantes
on touche à l'extrême droite dans sa
nature la plus la plus raciste
la plus violente si certains sites ne
sont plus accessibles aujourd'hui
d'autres sont toujours en fonctionnement
qui assimile je cite les palestiniens à
des déchets des sites hébergés à
l'étranger qui échappe à la législation
française anti raciste